[Music]
good morning my name is Lloyd Danzig I'm
the chairman and founder of ice day I
wear a 501c3 nonprofit dedicated to
ethical issues in the artificial
intelligence space and I'm also the
founder and CEO of sharp alpha advisors
we're a sports gaming business and
investment consultancy with a focus on
companies deploying cutting-edge tech
and at the intersection of those two
disciplines lies that which I'm here to
present to you a modern love story
machine learning engines and the global
sports betting industry so I want to
start just by way of agenda by giving a
quick overview into what the state of
this industry is particularly here in
the US right now discuss the two main
competing revenue models that you see
most commonly discuss how predictive
analytics have played a role in the
space historically talk about some of
the next gen statistics that are being
collected and fed into some of the
modern models and then get to the bulk
of the presentation a deep dive into the
various machine learning use cases and
then of course happy to take any
questions if not I have office hours
from 1:15 to 2 o'clock right after lunch
so for anyone who's not aware last May a
1992 piece of legislation known as pasta
the professional and amateur sports
Protection Act was repealed thereby
granting each state the authority to
decide if how and when to regulate
sports betting within the confines of
their borders I have behind me the most
recent iteration of the legalization map
put out by the American Gaming
Association its current as of a couple
of days ago and I think there are two
macro takeaways here one is that an
extraordinary amount of work has been
done by policymakers in a relatively
short period of time especially given
how long policies often take to be made
about 18 months is what was taken to
produce the map behind us but there
still exists an incredibly fractured
legislative landscape that more likely
than not is serving as an impediment
both to investment and innovation
nonetheless the economic impact has been
fantastic it's estimated that a fully
mature sports betting market in the US
would add 41 billion dollars in total
output across not only taxes and labor
income but ancillary services technology
and the like
not to mention between 125 and
approximate
150,000 jobs expected to be created all
here in the US some future trends to be
aware of wouldn't be relevant if I
didn't talk about eSports and betting on
eSports customers and fans are expected
to wager over 30 billion dollars on he
sports competitions next year alone
generating over 2 billion dollars in
revenue from the people who operate
those sports books new jersey during the
current League of Legends Championship
is the first state in the u.s. to
officially sanction
legal and regulated eSports betting
there are some challenges one is a lack
of reliable data and two is the prospect
of match fixing but nonetheless anyone
who is even vaguely familiar with the
space knows there has clearly been a
paradigm shift in what is considered a
sport and what people like to be fans of
and wager on the outcomes of sports
betting BOTS function just as they do on
Wall Street and financial services you
have sophisticated forecasting models
that particularly like to pursue
arbitrage opportunities algorithmically
and instantaneously when they arise as
with many industries the blockchain use
cases are pretty compelling for online
casinos in general you have digital
blackjack tables and roulette wheels
that are stamping the result of every
hand and spin on a distributed immutable
ledger so that in the long term you can
reconcile the distribution of outcomes
with the odds and the payouts that were
advertised at first and this has given
rise to this term provably fair gaming
something that many people who may have
played online blackjack in the past
perhaps doubted what was actually in
place in terms of sports betting the
ability to use fully-funded essentially
digitally escrowed smart contracts
offers this notion of guaranteed and
instantaneous payouts something that
again especially with people who have a
history of betting with offshore bookies
and unsanctioned companies have not
exactly had the luxury of enjoying there
are two competing revenue models in this
space the first is what you'll see if
you go to Las Vegas Atlantic City you
log on to draft kings or FanDuel and
that is called a fixed odds sports book
and that is one in which a customer
views odds that are set by the operator
and chooses whether or not to engage
with them so to use a hypothetical
example I have this little table on the
top right of a matchup between the
Knicks and the Pistons and the way you
would read this is if you look in the
second
of numbers the plus five-and-a-half
means the Knicks are five and a half
point underdogs if you want to bet on
them you look at the final score you add
five and a half to the Knicks see who
won and whoever wagered on that team
wins that particular bet
but for this hypothetical example on the
talk about the first column of numbers
which is what is known as the money line
these are the odds on which you bet on a
team to win regardless of the margin of
victory the plus again indicating an
underdog so a $100 wager on the Knicks
if successful would lead to a $190
profit that is the definition of plus
190 whereas the minus indicates a
favorite meaning if you wanted a bet on
the Pistons you would risk
$225 to win 100 the definition of minus
225
so suppose we had two hypothetical
customers Alice and Bob Alice wants to
risk $100 on the proposition that New
York will win while Bob wants to risk
$225 on the proposition that New York
will lose it's a basketball game binary
event only two possible outcomes either
New York wins in which case the sports
book returns Alice's initial stake plus
her winnings and O what do you know
there's some profit left over for them
or New York loses the sports book
returns Bob's initial stake in wager and
although there is no profit there's no
loss as well a key thing here though is
that this essentially or seemingly
riskless operation is only available if
you have the proper proportions of
wagers in terms of dollar amount on
either side of a market and that is
something difficult that sports book
operators have to do however those who
operate what is called a betting
exchange the much more popular
methodology or modality over in Europe
do not have to a betting exchange for
anyone with financial services
experience functions identically to a
limit order book on a futures exchange
we're willing participants are matched
in peer-to-peer fashion and serve as
counterparties for one another the
exchange simply provides the platform
the technology they have no counterparty
risk they have no risk insofar as the
outcome of any given game is concerned
so suppose our again our customer Alice
and by the way for reference the odds
from the previous slide are on the top
right suppose Alice had a model that
said New York had a 33 percent chance of
winning which would be represented at
fair odds of plus 203 which means you
wager 100 to win 203 dollars we remember
that the sports book
only offering +1 90 meaning for that
same hundred dollars risk you would only
win one 90 and often this disparity is
caused by two things the sports book
needs to be compensated for providing
liquidity and also for exposing itself
to information asymmetries two things
that the exchange does not have to in
which case the savings are usually
passed on to users in the form of more
favorable odds so what Alice might do is
go on the exchange and say hey does
anyone want to take Detroit - 203
because if someone else risks 203
dollars to win 100 on the proposition
that New York loses and Alice has the
other side of that that is the same
thing as her wagering $100 at the
prospect of winning 203 on the
proposition that New York wins and if
you recall before Bob only had the
opportunity to risk $225 to win a
hundred so he'd love to accept the
opportunity to risk only 203 to win the
same amount now of course they have to
make money somehow the exchanges usually
do that by taking the equivalent of a
rake or a commission starting at about
5% of winnings so what that would look
like again in our binary event is either
New York wins in which case Bob pays
Alice small percentage of which goes to
the exchange or New York loses in which
case Alice pays Bob and again a small
percentage goes to the exchange but if
you wanted to look at this net of fees
after paying any commissions how would
these customers have fare you can see
here how much they each would have won
if they correctly predicted the outcome
of the game and wagered $100 at the
sports book and you can see even after a
five percent commission both of them are
better off having used the exchange
somewhat inversely if you want to know
how much what each of them have had to
risk I'm sorry how much of them have to
risk to win $100 you can see again at
the exchange both parties have to risk
less to win the same amount and
ultimately all parties are better off
having used the exchange regardless of
which revenue model you choose either as
an operator or as a customer clearly the
linchpin is the odds at which these
various propositions are bet on and you
may wonder where these have come from
historically so let's just step back and
make sure to level set and see if
everyone is familiar with a particular
type of stochastic simulation known as
Monte Carlo simulation I'm sure most are
but but just to start from scratch
suppose I had asked you what the
probability was of rolling a 1 on a
single throw of a six-sided die
I'm sure everyone in here knows very
quickly that's a v16 then approximately
16.7% but for the less mathematically
inclined what you could do is take a
six-sided die roll it maybe a hundred
thousand times tally up all the results
convert those two frequencies and say
given my sample size I'm reasonably
confident that the frequency with which
each outcome occurred during my
simulation is predictive of the outcome
with which it will occur going forward
of course no one here wants to or even
could roll the six sided die a hundred
thousand times completely independently
but fortunately your favorite
spreadsheet programs and programming
languages allow you to do this many many
times very very quickly you can see the
syntax for Excel in Python in the top
right how does this apply to sports you
might ask well historically most odds
have been created and certainly if you
go on espn.com and see the probability
with which a win is expected using
something that builds off this exact
type of simulation so here I used real
data for the Yankees Red Sox game that
took place in London back in June and
pretty simply I first tallied up the
average number of runs that each team
had scored until that point and the
average number of runs scored against
them and then applied a very common
transformation in this space which is
designed to reflect the fact that for
any given quality of a team's offense
the quality of their opponent's defense
will affect the likelihood with which
you would expect them to achieve any
given level of output will of course
want to take into account the standard
deviation or some form of variability in
terms of their offensive output and then
we'll use the inverse of the cumulative
normal distribution function and feed it
three parameters in our case a random
value between 0 and 1 to start and then
the average adjusted a run scored for
each team and the standard deviation
thereof and once we have fed a random
value between 0 and 1 for the Yankees
and the Red Sox congratulations we have
simulated a matchup the Yankees won by a
score of ten point one four seven to
seven point nine four five both of which
of course are rounded and to make this
similar to our dice example and bring
this full circle we don't only do this
once but in this case I did it 10,000
times iterated through that simulation
so that I could tally up the frequency
with which each team won and either
convert those into odds if I were an
operator if I were draftkings at which
people could wager or as a customer
compare those two prevailing odds and
see if I see a relative
value opportunity now if you were gonna
do a real-world version of this you
actually wanted to take or make wagers
based on this data there would be a
whole host of other parameters you'd
want to include home-field advantage
injuries momentum various dynamics
whether in the light and on that note I
wanted to take just a couple of minutes
and talk about some of the
next-generation statistics that are not
only being collected but also fed into
some of these models so computer vision
is the sort of class of algorithms that
help machines interpret images and
videos and they've been used as
broadcasting tools for a while now
you've probably seen some of the
different use cases whether you've
realized it or not explanatory augmented
reality for example whereby graphics are
overlaid on the field or the court so
that fans have an easier time
interacting with or understanding a game
competitor overlays that you're probably
most familiar with if you've watched the
Olympics and seen for example how
Michael Phelps is tracking against that
yellow line that shows the pace of the
world record setter viewpoint synthesis
whereby an entirely new vantage point
usually for the purpose of a slow-motion
replay is created that was not directly
interpreted or at least captured by a
camera in real time and then the newest
and definitely most relevant to our
discussion is performance analysis where
cameras capture images and interpret
them in a way that allows them to
measure the position orientation and
velocity of every player on a field up
to and often in excess of 25 times per
second so before I show some pretty cool
applications from this last year's MIT
Sloan Sports analytics conference I like
to put this comic up where I have a
supervisor sign or developer we want to
make an app that allows users to upload
photos and tells whether they're in a
national park developer says sure easy
GIS lookup no problem says I also want
to check with the photos with a bird and
the research and the developer says I
need a research team in five years and
the point here is that if you're not
intimately acquainted with and kind of
constantly working in the fields of
computer vision it's not always entirely
intuitive what the relative difficulty
of various tasks are it doesn't always
map on to our more intuitive
understanding of what is and is not
difficult nonetheless here you'll see a
basketball scene that any fans will
quickly notice as Michael Jordan playing
against the Utah Jazz in 1998 game
and what you can see here that's
impressive to me in terms of this
computer vision system is not only how
accurate it is despite the low 1998
resolution of this broadcast but also
how tight the tracking main is
maintained even when the players bodies
sort of overlap as a Jets fan I hate
playing this clip but this is the famous
Odell Beckham jr. one-handed catch from
the 2014 Sunday Night Football game
against the Cowboys that took place
right across the river and aside from
the Freak athleticism on display what's
incredible here is how similar so many
of these overlapping pixel groups are
the players have almost the exact same
color socks the exact same color pants
there's blue in the jerseys the helmets
the spray-paint on the grass in the
endzone and still this system does an
unbelievable job at maintaining a really
accurate mapping of what objects exist
and where in the real physical world and
then finally we have the Germany Sweden
game from the World Cup Germany kicking
a free free-kick with a man down and
with this showcases again aside from
some really nice shot placement is first
of all the ability to recognize multiple
bodies on the same screen at the same
time and second of all to seamlessly
transition from one camera angle to
another one of those things that might
seem not that difficult but actually is
really not easy at all in addition to
computer vision we have wearables which
are not only consumer facing but at the
enterprise level as well we have
tracking chips in footballs that the NFL
uses in pads and jerseys and these have
allowed for some really interesting
real-time data analysis that is not only
real-time but incredibly granular
biometric feedback is something that is
interesting if not also controversial
are you going to be able to bet over
under Tom Brady's heartbeat in beats per
minute going to the last drive I don't
know it's it's an interesting concept
people are toying with but what remains
very obvious is that there is an
unprecedented level of insight being
offered into the nuances of how
competitive sports games unfold and how
advantages are gained and lost so we
have all this data what what are we
doing with it well the idea is that
there's a paradigm shift that is also
taking place a move away from these
stochastic simulations and into more
machine learning based models there are
a variety of use cases in them in the
sports gaming field that but
five that are really the most common and
the most important to know about if
you're interested in seeing how this
trend is taking place I'm going to go
into each of these much more deeply but
the first would be handicapping or the
process of odds making the next would be
risk management the third would be bet
recommendations finally responsible
gaming and fraud detection and before I
go into each of those I do like to issue
some causes for concern I'm a major
advocate of deploying AI across the
space I think there are an enormous
number of stakeholders that stand to
gain an incredible amount of value but
that doesn't mean it should necessarily
be applied haphazardly and one of my
chief concerns is this idea of backdoor
functionality where there are a ton of
third party tech companies developing
complicated software solutions that they
license out typically in white label
fashion to sports betting companies that
not only lack the technical wherewithal
to create the solutions in-house but to
look under the hood and understand what
it is that they are buying and not only
does that often lead to a variety of
mismatched incentives and expectations
but it gives rise to a situation where
those third party tech companies can
install the ability to scrape things
like valuable customer or operational
data completely unbeknownst to the
person operating the software the black
box problem is one that is obviously
endemic to the entire AI space and just
describes the phenomenon by which
incredibly complex algorithms sometimes
give rise to unexpected or even
undesired results that can't be
explained or traced back to their source
especially if you were paying attention
to the last talk IBM is a major advocate
of explainable AI for exactly this
reason the flash crash potential is
something that anyone in financial
services or has followed the markets
will be aware of and again since making
a financial investment and making a
sports wager are both about mass
maximizing risk adjusted return there is
an interesting case to be made that
anything you've seen happen in the
financial industry you can see happen in
the sports gaming industry as well and
the potential for a sort of
algorithmically Robo driven flash
crashes is one of those potentials and
then odds manipulation and fraud masking
are merely symptoms of the fact that
just as much as AI can be used by the
good guys it can be used by the bad guys
too
circumvent those efforts as well and
then finally on this sort of dreary note
before we get to the more fun stuff I do
like to say that although I see this in
a lot of spaces I see it especially
commonly in the sports gaming space
where there's this gold rush everyone
wants to have an AI powered system and a
machine-learning powered risk management
platform and so what's happening is some
tech companies are just advertising
solutions that are far less
sophisticated than they purport to be
because they don't expect anyone to be
calling them out and really again
looking under the hood and even being
able to make that assessment in terms of
handicapping or the the process of odds
making I've split this as the industry
generally does into pre-match which
describe odds on which you make wagers
before a game begins and in play which
we'll discuss in a second which describe
odds at which you make wagers once a
game is already in progress in terms of
the pre-match handicapping I think that
these ought benefits all need to be
viewed not only in the context of you
know increasing accuracy and reducing
human error but potentially over the
long term freeing up more human capital
to be deployed elsewhere in the
organization we've seen from the
previous section how much data an
increasingly large amount of data is
available so it should come as no
surprise that having an edge in
identifying nonlinear relationships or
analyzing large data sets would be
majorly advantageous and very preferable
to draftkings for example trying to gain
an edge against fan bull as I play this
clip of a neural network teaching itself
to recognize eminence digits you can
imagine that anyone who is in an
incredibly data-driven industry would be
interested in deploying models that have
the ability to improve their own
accuracy without an incredible amount of
human intervention and oversights
it's simply very appealing as is this
notion of transfer learning whereby for
example work that is done to train a
model that will be used to predict the
outcomes of basketball games can at
least seed or lay the foundation for a
model that is going to be used to
predict the outcomes of baseball games
it's in play way during live wagering
however where machine learning really
really adds a tremendous amount of value
and not only in terms of short-term
profitability but also by really vastly
improving the user experience and
hopefully boosting customer attend
and that is especially important in an
industry right now where cost of
customer acquisition ranges between
seven to nine hundred dollars and these
costs seem to only be increasing while
the high availability of substitute
products corresponding with virtually no
switching costs sometimes make it
difficult to realize the lifetime value
of the customer that you're probably
comparing against that cost of customer
acquisition so simply the prospect of
putting out accurate real-time odds with
confidence there's a time out what are
the new odds going to be in the Seahawks
game that is not something that
operators have had the luxury of doing
there's been an enormous amount of
uncertainty historically simply because
and segwaying into the second use case
historically most operators have used
the most robust possible model to set
odds before the game begins and then a
significantly trimmed down model to
update those odds in real times simply
because that first robust model is not
efficient enough to be run in the small
space between downs between timeouts
between batters etc and what this
sometimes gives rise to is
inconsistencies in odds that can be
exploited by arbitrage seekers and that
is a really nothing less than a death
wish for a sports book operator to have
arbitrage opportunities being pursued
algorithmically by the equivalent of
high-frequency traders for anyone who's
not familiar with the space either from
a business or consumer perspective
something that is very common which who
would never fly in on Wall Street is the
prospect of suspending markets for any
number of reasons new information comes
in suspicious betting patterns
unbalanced exposures you can go on to
draftkings for example go to place a bet
that you're excited to place especially
live and during the middle of the match
and find that they simply have stopped
taking wagers on that momentarily
perhaps permanently for the rest of the
game and from a draftkings from an
operator perspective not only is every
minute spent not taking expected value
positive wagers technically financially
detrimental but those are minutes in
which your customer might go to one of
your many competitors and then never be
seen again
so the use of machine learning to really
minimize both the frequency and duration
of suspensions is again not only
a thing that drives short-term
profitability but long-term customer
retention and growth as well and then
finally in segwaying into the next slide
risk management really is one of the
most important functions that a sports
betting company and essentially what
they do if you recall from the slides
earlier they try to get a properly
proportional amount of wagers on either
side of a market and they do that by
changing the odds - hopefully tug at the
supply and demand and kind of get those
into the equilibrium that they need
machine learning offers the ability not
only to run much more robust models in
real time but also to predict betting
patterns look at things like user
profiles and behavioral patterns and
really have a much more streamlined and
real-time and optimized risk management
system and so on that note being able to
balance a book in real time make sure
that the outcome of the game is not
going to affect profitability being able
to efficiently implement suspensions but
then also revoke them as quickly as
possible all ladders up to something
that increases the turnover turnover
being the industry term for total
dollars of wagers taken that a given
operator has the capacity to handle bet
recommendations are something that very
soon will function just as the way in
which Netflix keeps you watching and
Facebook keeps you scrolling right now
if we were to log on to an online sports
book we would all see the same set of
promotions but of course as is the case
in most of the rest of the e-commerce
and tech space that doesn't really make
sense and it certainly is not the wave
of the future so if you knew for example
that a particular customer had a
preference for a specific type of
promotion maybe they like having their
payouts boosted rather than their losses
refunded maybe you have unbalanced
exposure to a team that plays in a
geography where you have a lot of
current active users on the website or
maybe a particular cohort has an
affinity for betting on the number of
yards that a given receiver is going to
attain rather than a tight end and
whatever these factors are machine
learning is particularly efficient at
helping analyze classify and create a
more curated and customized and
hopefully profit maximizing and
enjoyable user flow for all of the end
users responsible gaming is another
industry term that it defines the class
of tools or mechanisms that help keep
customers from falling victim to the
ills of gambling addiction and right now
they really exist primarily in the form
of self-imposed restrictions or self
exclusions I as a quick aside I really
don't like the term responsible Gaming I
think the term sustainable gaming is
better because it does a better job of
conferring this notion that keeping
Vicky 'pink customers out of addictive
behavior and preserving the integrity of
underlying sporting events doesn't only
affect a few people but every
stakeholder in the sports gaming space
and actually every stakeholder in the
sports entertainment space more broadly
and again without going into too much
detail here you can imagine that rather
than just having self-imposed
restrictions and self exclusions having
behavioral profiles where you track how
different users who have different
betting patterns might interact with
your website and the odds over time how
they act on a Saturday at 2:00 a.m.
might be different from their
conventional conventional betting
patterns at noon on a weekday betting
only basketball and then one day they
start betting baseball or all these
indicators that really just show how
sort of this pattern recognition on
steroids notion of machine learning can
be really helpful in operators ability
to proactively assess deviations from
responsible gaming and hopefully cut off
a problem before it starts last but not
least this idea of fraud detection
especially prevalent over in Europe and
I think is on some people's radars here
in the US but not to the extent that it
will be the gambling industry has
historically always attracted a lot of
fraudsters and the people trying to
perpetrate these frauds are growing more
sophisticated and technically complex
and using a lot more resources in their
efforts and so using machine learning to
detect things like betting and
syndicates trying to exploit bonus
systems betting on behalf of third
parties and arbitrage seeking are all
going to be necessary simply from
keeping up with sort of the status quo
perspective so to sort of recapitulate
that was handicapping our odds making
risk management bet recommendations
responsible or hopefully sustainable
gaming and fraud detection with that
happy to take any questions and again if
not I have office hours from 1:50
two o'clock thank you very much hey
there could you talk a bit about maybe
some of them from more of like an
ethical standpoint how do you think
about like the data input all these
models and how different companies have
access to different amounts of data is
that a fair way of doing it if someone's
like TV tape-delayed
on their stream like they're ten seconds
behind people who are not who are
they're like how do you deal yeah look
so it's a it's actually a really great
question that might speak to even a
bigger controversy than you're even
aware of and I'll kind of give the
breakdown so right now there's a massive
tension between sports betting operators
draftkings and FanDuel of the world and
the leaks NBA MLB and the like the
league's want it to be legally required
in every state that in order to offer
odds on a sporting event you have to buy
that data usually at an astonishing
price from the league itself or its
officially licensed data distributor of
course it's kind of weird the league's
are almost claiming that the data that
they're games produce is their
intellectual property which is a bit of
a weird claim you go to Madison Square
Garden you watch a Knicks game someone
makes a basket it seems weird that
someone can own the piece of information
that says the time at which that took
place but nonetheless Illinois and I
believe Mississippi or maybe time to see
there are two states that have legally
mandated that you have to buy the data
from the league's or they're officially
license partners and this is definitely
like if you're looking at a pitch deck
for an investor pitch a classic risk
that people describe is is the cost of
data going to sort of go up and there
really is a virtual monopoly that exists
in the field where if if the NBA owns
their own data you by definition can't
get it from anyone else and so that's
one thing is just the cost of data and
sort of concentration of resources and
things like that but I think from a
different app that's sort of the
business and economic ethics from a
personal and privacy ethical standpoint
I mentioned the the wearables it is a
very real thing that someone who's
betting a lot of money might want to
know what
Tom Brady's blood pressure before the
game and what is his heart rate and how
has that trended over time and you can
see all these pieces of information that
would be of genuine and real value to
gamblers but that would perhaps start to
maybe cross a line if that has not been
crossed already in terms of personal
privacy I was at a conference last
Wednesday and this is funny but someone
told me that they bet on women's sports
by first of all somehow they've they
have some model or something where they
think they can predict menstrual cycles
and they bet against women at certain
points other people who look at NBA
players wives on Twitter and when it
seems there's unrest in the marriage bet
against that player to score a certain
number of points and I can see a lot of
the reactions on your faces like all
right that's cool but like kind of
creepy and and you're right it sort of
is and I think this whole notion of what
it means to be a celebrity and once you
have taken the extra money that comes
with celebrity what the lack of privacy
it is that goes alongside that is
changing very radically and so it's a
great question not only from the ethics
of who owns the data and if you want to
offer out odds should someone be able to
mandate what type of data goes into that
model it's kind of a unique proposition
but also from a personal privacy
standpoint with biometrics and wearables
and the ability to collect data on
people without them knowing that you're
collecting it it's really interesting so
I don't have a direct answer in terms of
what I think the right thing is but I'll
tell you that for sure
the ethics surrounding data collection
and analysis and use both from an
economic and a personal privacy
standpoint are at the forefront of a lot
of the legislative and regulatory
debates right now great question thank
you so I had a follow-up because I've
actually worked a little bit in that
space and I was very curious first of
all I think you're absolutely right it's
only a few people own the data so you
can't really look at it but I I was
reading something else into something
sure at the end which is you can
potentially get people addicted to
behaviors by understanding their
patterns of betting and kind of skewing
them towards having more opportunities
so you mentioned regulation are there
regulations to help us do the equivalent
of explainable to understand what's
happening with the data and the
predictions and the things you see and
the second part of the question was also
what rights do the users have
sir so the first question is is is about
you know regulation essentially what if
any regulations exists that are put in
place to either protect businesses and
entrepreneurs in terms of the costs at
which they acquire data or you know the
players and the like from what personal
data is being revealed and the answer to
that is as is the case with most fields
of regulation the regulators are
struggling to just understand the
absolute baseline of what they need
right now there are not many Gaming
regulators internationally that know
what machine learning is let alone data
analytics or virtually any of the
terminology that's being discussed here
something that I do is as I do speak out
and consult for various regulatory
bodies and try to educate them on a what
technologies should they be using and B
what technologies should they be aware
of their adversary is using the reality
is that they wanna they right now
you know there's this state's verse of
battle going on and there's so much that
I just don't I think it's on their radar
conceptually but not something that that
they're looking at too tightly
especially since sort of the powers that
be the the economic powers are the
leagues and the ones who own the data
and although it is weird for the NBA to
say that you know a basket being scored
as a data point that they own it is the
case that if the NBA didn't exist you
would by definition not be able to wager
on it and that's kind of their claim
that if we didn't have a sport you would
not have ads to even be making and
taking bets on in terms of personal
privacy this is a place where you know
entities like the ACLU are starting to
clash with the NBA sport radar William
Hill's and and the like and again I
think a blanket answer to almost any
question anyone would ask is that we're
in the top maybe bottom of the first
inning of this industry there are 14
states where sports betting is legal and
active and expected to head up towards
the 4850 mark by 2025 everyone is just
getting stuff settled the states don't
even have things a kind of in
coordination with each other New Jersey
has a tax rate of eight point two five
percent for sports that bets taken in
person and fourteen point two five or
seven five four one's taken online
Pennsylvania has a fifty-one
percent tax rate draftkings is the
exclusive provider in New Hampshire
because they bid that they would share
51% of their revenue with the state and
outbid all the other operators in order
to do that
New York has brick-and-mortar sports
betting allowed upstate but none on
mobile Tennessee has mobile only and not
in brick-and-mortar so it's tough to
apply some of the conventional logic
that you would apply to any other
industry where you'd say ok this seems
like an obvious place for a regulator a
compliance officer the reality is
everyone is trying to kind of drink from
a fire hose right now and figure out
what opportunities to pursue and in what
order
it's an incredibly capital-intensive
business to be in draftkings operates at
a maybe 2 to 3% margin at the end of the
day and so it is absolutely needed
I think players are starting to grow
concerned about who owns their data
especially things like I'm just guessing
there are no open data sets right in
this space so there there are no open
data sets except the NFL for example
usually does like a partnership with
Kaggle once a year to do a Super Bowl of
analytics and they'll release some sort
of open source data endpoint the NFL
games or something there was an endpoint
you could drag data from right and now
look there are there are there sites
that anyone who has ever scraped sports
data will know Pro Football Reference
comm baseball-reference comm Basketball
Reference comm but I would not consider
it right that's not a league sanction
data point those are other people
somewhere in the middle of these are a
company like sports info solutions for
example that has subsidiaries like
baseball info solutions and what
baseball info solutions does is a bit
before the advent of computer vision is
they have 40 people whose full-time jobs
it is to watch baseball games on a
touchscreen and every at-bat say ok
here's where all of the nine fielders
are here's where the ball landed and
that creates what looks like to the
end-user an officially sanctioned MLB
data set you know how else would they
get all this information and reality it
was just a ton of of course error-prone
sort of human effort so the short answer
is no no open data sets except for those
kind of one-off partnerships
[Music]